c'est le moment du réquisitoire la cour
a se prononcer sur le sort de quatorze
accusés 300 présumé mort ou en fuite
mort les frères belhoucine en fuite
échappés dès qu'on kurde hayat
boumédiène les 14 accusés encourent
entre dix ans de prison et la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
et depuis ce matin julie holveck et jean
michel bourlet ses avocats généraux
s'exprime en quoi consiste ce
réquisitoire je vous propose d'écouter
catherine svarc avocats de parties
civiles
alors les avocats généraux se succèdent
ils ont vraiment décidé de 2
de ce passé la parole pour pour aborder
chaque point précis ils ont fait une
présentation générale de tout ce qui
s'est passé tant au niveau des victimes
pour leur vécu en le rappelant qu'au
niveau des accusés fin des auteurs
directs qui ne sont plus là mais il
fallait bien rappelé les actes pour
ensuite aborder les complicités et les
participations et là ils sont en train
de détailler le chronologiquement tous
les éléments de participation qui montre
les la complicité et l'association de
malfaiteurs terroristes qui est reproché
aux accusés
donc l'avocat général
quand même mentionner le fait que nous
sommes évidemment dans un état de droit
et que la justice c'est aussi de faire
la part des choses et faire la part des
responsabilités avec des degrés de
responsabilité qui ne sont pas les mêmes
pour tous les accusés avec minutie les
avocats généraux recense les mensonges
les incohérences les changements de
versions des accusés il accumule les
éléments qui prouvent les contacts
téléphoniques entre mehdi coulibaly et
eux les rencontres physiques 1 jusqu'à
la veille des attentats défaire kwasi
des éléments qui pourraient s'avérer
accablant et pour le moment les accusés
ne réagissent pas dans le box
le réquisitoire se terminera demain midi
suivi des plaidoiries des avocats de la
défense premier à plaider
isabelle coûtant peyre c'est l'avocate
du principal accusé ali riza paul est
suspecté de complicité avec amedi
coulibaly il encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité